- [Instructor] We are told
that quadrilateral ABCD
is dilated about point P.
So this is our quadrilateral
that's going to be dilated around point P.
And then they ask us some questions.
Are the coordinates of
the vertices preserved?
Are corresponding line
segments on the same line?
Are angle measures preserved?
Are side lengths, perimeter,
and area preserved?
So pause this video and
see if you can answer it.
So now let's work through it together.
So one thing you might be thinking
is they're just saying it's dilated.
They didn't say what the scale factor is.
We know it's dilated about point P,
but what's the scale factor?
Well since they didn't tell us,
I guess these questions would
apply to any scale factor.
But to help us visualize this,
let's just supply a scale factor here.
Let's just say that our scale factor,
scale factor, so it fits on this page,
is equal to 1/2.
So what would result here?
Well right now point A is one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight
away from point P.
So its image if we do
a scale factor of 1/2
would be four away.
One, two, three, four.
So right over there, point
A' could be right over there.
It would be along the same line,
it would just be 1/2 as far.
Point D is right now one, two,
three, four, five six away.
So D' would be three away,
half as far away.
And so this would be the segment A'D'
which corresponds to the segment AD.
Now let's see,
point B, if we have a scale factor of 1/2,
it is one, two, three, four,
five, six below A.
But if we have a scale factor of 1/2,
it's going to be three below A.
So this would be our B'.
And so you could also see
that if you connect a line
going from point P to B that
B' is also on that line.
It's just 1/2 as far, scale factor of 1/2.
Now point C,
there's a couple of ways
we could think about it.
To go from point P to point C,
we have to go four down
and two to the left.
So if you apply a scale factor of 1/2,
you go two down and one to the left.
So this would be C' right over here.
And so A'B'C'D',
the image of quadrilateral
ABCD after the dilation
around point P,
and I picked an arbitrary
scale factor here
that I felt that I could draw,
you see it right over here.
And the reason why I
did that is it makes it
a little bit easier to
answer this question.
Are the coordinates of
the vertices preserved?
Well every vertex, all the vertices,
are different coordinates here.
So we would say no, none
of those are preserved.
Are the, and the whole
idea here is to appreciate
what gets preserved
or doesn't get preserved under dilations.
Are corresponding line
segments on the same line?
Well let's see, no,
they're all parallel to each other,
so AB is parallel to A'B',
AD is parallel to A'D',
and so on and so forth.
But they're not all, none of
them are on the same line,
so I would say no.
And then we say are
angle measures preserved?
So this is something that
dilations do preserve.
So this angle is still
the same as that angle.
This was a right angle before,
it's still a right angle.
This angle is still equal to that angle
or the measure of those angles.
Likewise the measure of that angle
is still equal to the
measure of that angle.
So angle measures are preserved.
And that's a general thing
that you could take away
about dilations.
Are side lengths, perimeter,
and area preserved?
Well dilations are a
non-rigid transformation
which tells you that side
lengths are not preserved.
The distance between corresponding
points are not preserved.
You can see it very clearly here.
And if side lengths aren't preserved,
then perimeter is
definitely not preserved,
and then area would not be preserved.
So this would be no for all of these
under a dilation.
If we were talking about
a rigid transformation
like a translation or a rotation,
then these three would be preserved.
Let's do another example.
So we're told triangle ABC
is dilated about point C.
Once again they don't tell
us what the scale factor,
and then they ask us
the same four questions.
So like before, pause this video,
see if you can figure it out on your own.
Now let's work through it together,
and I'm just going to
apply a scale factor.
In fact you know might as
well do a scale factor of 1/2.
So scale factor, I'll
just do S.F. for short,
let's say it's equal to 1/2.
And I'm just picking one
so that we can visualize
what its image would look
like after the dilation.
So let's see,
right now and remember this is interesting
because we're dilating around a point
that happens to be one of
the vertices of the triangle.
So let's see, point A, to go from C to A,
we go three to the left
and we go two, four, six up.
Six up.
Just like that.
So two to the left and then six up.
So if you have a scale factor of 1/2,
or sorry not two to the
left, three to the left,
three to the left and six up.
And so if you have a scale factor of 1/2,
instead you're gonna go 1 1/2 to the left
and then three up.
And so you're gonna end
up right over there.
Now this is A'.
And so notice this is actually
sitting on the segment AC,
and that happens to be the case
because once again,
our center of dilation
is one of the vertices
of our actual triangle.
Now let's look at think
about where B' would be.
To go from C to B we go two to the right,
and then we go four up, plus four.
So if we are talking about
a scale factor of 1/2,
we'll go 1/2 as far to the right
and 1/2 as far up.
So one to the right and two up,
so this would be where B' is.
And so there we have
the image, and of
course, C would map to C'
because it's actually the point
that we are dilating about.
So this would be our
image right over here,
A', B', and C'.
So are the coordinates of
the vertices preserved?
Well only, only C is preserved.
The other ones are not preserved.
And the only reason why C
was preserved is because
that is the point we are dilating about.
It's third time I said it, my apologies.
Are corresponding line
segments on the same line?
Well A'C' same
on same line I guess you could say,
on same line
as AC.
And similarly,
C'B' or I can say B'C' same.
I'm just gonna use a
little bit of shorthand.
And once again that is
because we are dilating
about a point that is one of the vertices.
The other segment A'B' is not.
Not A'B'.
It's not on the same line.
It is parallel.
This is parallel to that,
but it is not on the same line.
Are angle measures preserved?
Well we don't even have to look at this.
This is going to be a yes.
This is one of the things about dilation,
angle measures are preserved.
That angle's equal to that angle,
the measure of this angle
is congruent to that angle,
or this angle's congruent to that angle,
and of course this is the
same angle in both cases.
Are side lengths, perimeters,
and area preserved?
Once again no.
When we're doing a dilation side lengths,
and if side lengths aren't preserved,
perimeter's not gonna be preserved
and area's not gonna be preserved.
And we're done.